collines et au-dessus des prairies, les corbeaux
sentent l'ombre Oh en
avant une montagne à la recherche de la
façon de gagner des courses - bataille avec le tourbillon
le choc et la pourriture de Charlotte cherchant
maintenant celui dont le moment est venu de prendre
la lame mori et l'action couronne de guerre je
vois  ton visage je ne pleure plus Mori une
course de guerre antique viens avec moi sur tes
vents Mari et course de guerre absente J'entends une
voix Je ne respire plus Morrigan et la
couronne de guerre viens libère mon esprit
Oh pilules et autres métaux au  vol d'
oiseau sentir l'ombre tous les bois
une autre montagne à la recherche d'un mur
ses ailes et ses bretelles - se battre mais tourbillonner
le choc et la timidité le bruissement malade
de celui qui Stein est venu prendre la
lame plus Regan hamshank run of war Je
vois ton visage je  cria
Morrigan un gros morceau de guerre viens avec
moi sur tes ailes plus Regan absent
de la voix de guerre n'ai plus de souffle Marie
et je suis Synchrone de guerre viens sentir mes
esprits libres